Let us now come back to the
trajectory estimation problem
that we introduced earlier.
We have an object
that moves vertically.
At any given time t, the height
at which the object is found
is equal to this expression.
It corresponds to the
following-- the object starts
at time 0, at some
initial height Theta0,
it has an initial
velocity of Theta1,
but also has a
certain acceleration.
And if Theta2 is
negative, this will
be a downwards
acceleration, which
means that the object eventually
will turn and start going down.
So this is a typical trajectory
of such an object, where
here we're plotting the
height as a function of time.
However, the Thetas
are unknown and they
are random-- we do not
know what they are.
So this blue curve
is just a simulation
where we drew values for those
random variables at random.
But if we were to
simulate again,
we might obtain a somewhat
different blue curve,
because the values of the Thetas
might have been different.
We do not observe the
true trajectory directly.
What we do observe is
certain data points.
What are they?
At certain times ti
we make a measurement
of the height of the object,
except that this measurement
is corrupted by
some additive noise.
This is the model that
we introduced earlier.
And our assumptions were that
all of the random variables
involved-- the Thetas and the
W's were normal with 0 mean
and were also independent.
In that case, we saw that
maximizing the posterior
distribution of the Thetas
after taking logarithms
amounted to minimizing
this quadratic function
of the thetas.
So once we have some data
available in our hands,
we look at this expression
as a function of the thetas
and find the thetas that
are as as good as possible
in terms of this criterion.
And this is the MAP methodology
for this particular example.
Now, for the purposes
of this illustration,
actually, we will change our
assumptions a little bit.
They will be as follows.
Regarding the acceleration, we
will take it to be a constant.
The acceleration
term often has to do
with gravitational
effects which are known,
so we will treat
Theta2 as a constant.
And that means that
there's no point
in having a prior
distribution for Theta2.
So this term here,
which originated
from the prior distribution of
Theta2 is going to disappear.
We will take the variances of
these basic random variables
to be the same.
And because of this,
these constants
here will all be the same.
Therefore, we can take them
outside of this expression,
and outside the minimization
they will not matter.
So we can remove them
from the picture.
The factor of 1/2 can
also be removed similarly.
It does not affect
the minimization.
Finally, just in order to
get a nicer illustration,
instead of taking 0
means, we're assuming
that the initial position
has a mean of 200.
So we're starting
somewhere around here.
And furthermore, the initial
velocity has a mean of 50.
So we expect the object
to start moving upwards.
How does this change
the formulation?
Well, remember, that
this term and this term
originated from the priors
for Theta0 and Theta1.
If we now change the means,
the priors will change.
And what happens, if you recall
the formula for the normal PDF
and how the mean enters,
after you take logarithms,
you see that instead
of having here theta0,
you should have theta0 minus
the mean of theta0 squared.
And this leads us to the
following formulation.
So this is the formulation
that we will consider.
We obtain these data points,
and for these particular data
points and for known times at
which the measurements were
taken, we put these numbers
into this minimization, carried
it out numerically, and
this is what we got.
We got estimates for the
different parameters.
And using this estimates,
we can use this expression
to construct an
estimated trajectory.
And the estimated trajectory
is given by the red curve.
It seems to be doing
somewhat of a reasonable job,
but not quite.
The distance between these two
curves is quite substantial.
How could we do a little better?
Why is it that we're
not doing very well?
Let's think intuitively.
One of the parameters we
wish to estimate is Theta1.
And Theta1 is a velocity.
Now, all of our measurements
are concentrated
at pretty much the same time.
But if you measure an object
only at a certain time,
it is very difficult to
estimate its velocity.
A much better idea
would be to try
to measure the position of
the object at different times
and use that information
to estimate velocity.
So let us instead of
taking all the measurements
around the initial time,
have five measurements
in the beginning and five
measurements towards the end.
The total number of
measurements in this example
is the same as in
the previous example.
And once more, we generate
a simulated trajectory
according to the
probability distributions
that we are assuming.
Then we generate data
according to this model
and we wish to estimate
this trajectory.
We take the data, plug them
into this minimization,
carry it out numerically,
and this is what we obtain.
So we see that here we
are doing a lot better.
The estimated
trajectory is quite
close to the unknown
blue trajectory,
even though the data seems
to be scattered quite a bit.
This is a very nice property.
But is it just an accident
of this numerical experiment?
Or, also, to put it
differently, once you
get your estimated
trajectory, yes, it
is true that it is close
to the blue trajectory,
but you do not necessarily
know that fact.
It is one thing to
have an estimate that
is close to the true value,
and it's a different thing
to have an estimate
that you know
that it is close
to the true value.
So how could we get some
guarantees that, indeed, this
is the case, that we
have good estimates?
Here's how it goes.
As we discussed before,
the posterior distribution
of the Thetas given
the data is normal.
And for similar reasons,
the posterior distribution
of this quantity, which
is the true position,
it's what we denoted by X of t,
the posterior distribution of X
of t is also normal.
And in fact, what we obtain from
this diagram is at any given
point it's the maximum of
posteriority probability
estimate of the position
X of t at that time.
However, besides just
this point estimate,
we have additional information.
We know that the posterior
distribution of X of t
is normal.
And so, for example,
at this time,
this is the peak
of the posterior.
This is the maximum a
posteriori probability estimate.
By we are also able to calculate
the variance of this posterior
distribution.
This is a calculation
that's a bit complicated
for the multivariate
case, for the case where
you have multiple
unknown parameters.
We will not get into it.
But we did see
earlier an example
where we had a single
unknown parameter,
and in which we were
able to calculate
the variance of the
posterior distribution.
So the idea is somewhat similar.
So not only we have an
estimate for the position
of the object at
this particular time,
but we also have a
probability distribution
for what the true
position might be.
And once we have such
a posterior probability
distribution, we can find an
interval with the property
that 95% of the probability
is inside that interval.
In other words, we construct
an interval with the property
that the probability that X
of t belongs to the interval.
(Now, we're talking about
posterior probabilities.
So it is a posterior
probability, given the data.)
This probability
is, let's say, 0.95.
Such an interval gives useful
information besides a point
estimate, it also gives us
a range of possible values.
And outside this range,
it is quite unlikely
to have the true
trajectory be out there.
So here we're showing some
confidence intervals that
apply to different times,
and they're pretty narrow,
they're pretty small.
And they indicate,
they give us confidence
that we have pretty
accurate estimates
of the true trajectory.
This kind of
confidence intervals
that we have discussed in
the context of this examples
are called Bayesian
confidence intervals.
And they're very useful when
you report your results,
to not just give
point estimates,
but to also provide
confidence intervals.
Coming back to the
bigger picture, what
happened in this
particular example
is quite indicative of many
real world applications.
One starts with a
linear model, in which
we have a linear relation
between the variables that
are unknown and
the observations,
but where also the observations
are corrupted by noise.
One makes certain normality
and independence assumptions.
And as long as the modeling
has been done carefully
and the assumptions
are justified, then
by carrying out this
procedure, one usually
obtains estimates that are very
helpful and very informative.